at our southern border the crisis
continues a chief border patrol agent
says fentanyl seizures are increasing by
about 4
000 percent in just three years in el
paso as cartels take advantage of white
house policies here to react former
acting dhs deputy secretary ken
cuccinelli secretary how frightening
should this be to
every single american
look mark morgan used to like to say
that every town in america is a border
town
and this is why when you bring the
fentanyl across like that
across that border it's then free to
break through the rest of the country
and come to your hometown
and this is a killer killer drug and the
cartels
know they study what this administration
does or doesn't do
and they exploit the loopholes and when
you have a policy of
literally throwing the door open at the
border
you make their job easier than it has
ever been to kill americans and make a
lot of money
we've seen what the opioid crisis has
done to so many people across this
country i'm curious your opinion on
what type of damage has already been
done at our southern border that perhaps
we might not be able to come back from
that's a great question jillian because
you know
it's it's one thing to have lapses and
mistakes
it's quite another to undo entire
policies
that you have to then turn around and go
put back in place
we didn't put successful policies in
place overnight it took
months of work to prepare logistically
and legally because we always got sued
right
by the people that the vice president
met with last friday by the way when she
went to el paso
and and it takes a lot of time effort
and work
and so they can't even if they ever
develop the political courage
to start stemming the flow into this
country it isn't something that happens
at the snap of your fingers they've
already overwhelmed
both dhs and the hhs facilities holding
children
related to immigration so undoing all of
that
is going to take significant work and
significant amounts of time but it's
worth remembering
we're only five months in to this
terrible
policy if that's what it is yeah and
some democrats are even proposing
defunding immigration enforcement
agencies
amid all this 30 seconds to you sir
isn't that just
all of us just further proof that there
are a number of democrats
especially in the house that want open
borders 30 seconds to you
absolutely correct this is not a mistake
this is intentional
we look at the border and see open
borders and a terrible crisis for our
country
they see a voter registration line this
is a long-term plan for the radical left
even if they don't get it in their
election bill like they had in the bill
that failed last week
they pass amnesty bills they've got two
that have gone through the house already
they even get republican support for
some of those things and that we have to
watch out for
it is so alarming uh former acting dhs
deputy secretary ken cuccinelli thank
you for waking up early for us this
morning
your information is important